-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
We're about to play a very
special edition of charades
all about the '80s,
but first
we're gonna need some players.
Joining my team, his memoir,
"Waxing On:
The Karate Kid and Me,"
is available for pre-order now.
Please welcome Ralph Macchio!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-That's...
That's what I'm talking about,
buddy. Come on, bud.
That's my partner right there!
Come on!
-Whoo!
-And here's
who we'll be playing against.
You can see her
in "Luckiest Girl Alive"
coming to Netflix this Friday.
Give it up for Jennifer Beals!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Indistinct conversation ]
Jennifer Beals! Come on, now!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Joining Jennifer's team,
she stars in
"The Disappearance
of Cari Farver"
on Lifetime this Saturday.
Put your hands together
for Lea Thompson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
We're gonna have fun. I know it.
-Okay, did you see this?
-Are you kidding me?
Was that not planned?
-[Brooklyn accent]
We called each other.
-[Brooklyn accent] They called
each other on the phone.
"Yeah, I'm wearing pink."
Yeah. Exactly.
[Normal voice] Guys, now, all of
you know how to play charades.
We're gonna do four rounds.
30 seconds on the clock
per round.
Then the fifth round
is the showdown.
Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
And in honor of tonight's
special show,
all of our clues
are '80s themed.
-[ Gasps ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I will go first.
Everyone take their seats.
-Okay.
-Yeah. You're over there, Lea.
-Ralph, you're over there.
I will give the first clue.
What number should I choose?
[ Audience
shouting suggestions ]
-Seven.
-What?!
Wow!
-Oh, man.
-Wow. Alright. We got this.
But either way,
we love each other, right?
-Oh, we love each other.
-Good. That's all that matters.
-It's all about that.
-Okay. Alright.
I think we...got this?
Alright. We're ready?
Here we go.
-Movie. Two words.
First word.
Singing, talking.
"Talk Soup." No.
That's not the '80s.
"Talk Radio."
Second word.
Uh, I don't know.
Uh -- [ Stammering ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, come on, Ralph.
[ Stammering ]
Oh, my gosh. I'm failing.
Um, wait --
[ Buzzer ]
-Ohh!
-[ Sad tuba plays ]
-I was terrible.
Did you have it?
Do you have it?
-I just thought of the
last move. Ready for this.
Here's the move.
-Oh, wait. "Say Anything."
-I'm sorry.
-Dude!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-How did I mess that up?
How did I mess --
-Help me out.
-I'm so sorry.
Sorry to Cameron Crowe.
-Go with the iconic image.
-I'm sorry. I went with --
I went with the words.
Okay. Now we're learning.
Okay. Good.
Jennifer, you're up.
-Okay.
-I know. I'm learning, I'm
learning, I'm learning. Okay.
-It all makes sense now.
-What number? What number.
It does make sense.
[ Audience
shouting suggestions ]
Wow! Nice call.
It's not NOT confident.
-I'm so sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-You can't talk. You can't talk.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-Okay. Ooh.
-A song.
Fly.
Tears. My wings.
You are the --
Third word.
Cry. Nose.
-No. You got it.
-That means you get it.
-Okay. Cry.
Second word. Fly.
"Angels Cry."
"Only Angels Cry."
-You're gonna kick yourself
when you know.
Lea! Three words!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Together:
"When Doves Cry"!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-The foot.
-That was good.
Jennifer, that was good.
We got those.
Ralph, let's do it.
I'll redeem myself. I promise.
-Sorry, Team Pink.
-I know. We're all learning.
Here we go.
What number for Ralph?
[ Audience
shouting suggestions ]
-Three? Five? Six?
No. I'm going...
-Ooh, he's not feeling three.
I love this.
-I'm going six.
-Curveball.
Come on, bud. We got --
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-We got this, bud. Come on.
Okay. Movie. How many words?
Three words.
First word. At. The. On.
Ah. "A."
-Mm-hmm.
-Yep.
-"A" something something.
[ Laughter ]
Second word. Yes.
-Mmm!
-House. Mountain.
Gathering. Offering.
No. Never mind, never mind.
Third word --
[ Buzzer ]
-"A Christmas Story."
-Oh, my gosh. These are hard!
-What would you
have done for Christmas?
-This is a hard '80s theme.
-What would you
have done for Christmas?
-Yeah, I guess that was it.
You did a tree. Yes.
These are the hardest clues
I've ever seen.
Lea, good luck.
Wow! They're tough.
-Which --
-"Say Anything."
[ Audience
shouting suggestions ]
These are '80s themed. Okay.
[ Audience oohs ]
Gosh.
It sounds like the audience...
-This is a tough house.
-These are tough clues.
Come on.
We never played this before.
-Song. Four words.
First word. "Eye."
Small word.
I am -- I -- Ooh. I...
Third word.
-No.
-Fourth word.
-[ Snarls ]
I am a ti--
"Eye of the Tiger."
-Oh, my God!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I'm talking about.
That was good.
That was good, right?
Now we're getting it right here.
Okay. Now, here we go.
This is the showdown right here,
okay? This is it.
This one right here
is worth 5,000 points.
Can we say that?
-Yeah, I think so.
-Alright, now, we get to
choose who gives the clue.
I think, Ralph, you're better
at giving the clue.
-Oh, my God.
-I kind of whiffed on mine.
"Say Anything,"
I could have done that, right?
-Yeah, you could've d--
I'll take redemption.
-What do you think? Who's giving
the clue on your side?
-Whew!
-You want me to do it?
-Yeah, even though
I failed miserably.
-No worries.
a-Pick any number,
and whatever you do, whoever's
team guesses first wins.
What number shall we choose?
Five. Alright.
-Oh, we have to sit down.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yep. Here we go. Go.
-Song?
-Movie.
-Two words.
-Dance.
-Second word. Dance.
Something da--
"Flashdance."
-"Dirty Dancing."
-Oh, my -- No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The champions!
-I went...
-Jennifer Beals! Lea Thompson!
-Sweet.
-Ralph Macchio. Thank you.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show"
and a special performance
from Modern English.
"Dirty Dancing"!
♪♪